[Applaudissements]
j'ai grandi envoyé en famille d'accueil
un peu partout dans le monde en afrique
notamment en tanzanie
et vous savez quand vous arrivez dans un
nouveau pays on vous pose toujours plein
de questions pour vous demander un peu
de comparer le pays par rapport à
d'autres pays où vous avez vécu ou même
votre pays d'origine
c'est comme ça que je me retrouve face à
mon oncle d'accueil tanzanien kim
annonce fièrement qu'il espère que la
ville de dar es salaam ressemblera à
celle de paris en 2040
me voilà donc 700 euros de billets
d'avion paris dar es salaam plus tard à
me demander si mes parents auraient
payer la même somme pour l'équivalent
d'un baril paris
mais ce qui m'a le plus interpellé dans
cette discussion c'est que je me suis
demandé quel était le futur ainsi décrit
par mon oncle
qualité cette idée du développement
qu'on lui demandait d'incarner un
développement d'un pays si éloigné de la
france à qui on lui demandait pourtant
de lui ressembler
est-ce qu'on pouvais pas établir un lien
entre ces futurs projeté et des
décisions prises au quotidien
d'infrastructures touristiques à
zanzibar d'études en europe poursuivi
par certains de mes cousins d'accueil
ces années mais de toutes ces questions
que je me suis tourné vers ma profession
profession de futuriste ou de
spécialistes de l'anticipation
parce que j'étais convaincu de trois
choses
convaincu qu'il existait un lien entre
nos images du futur et les décisions que
nous prenons au quotidien au présent
convaincu qu'on gagnerait vrai appareil
vraiment du futur
convaincu également
qu'un bon usage du futur nous
permettrait de véritablement reprendre
le pouvoir
et j'aimerais vous en convaincre ce soir
et pourtant je sais que ce ne sera pas
forcément une chose simple
puisque l'une des premières questions
qu'on pose généralement aux futuriste
c'est de leur demander mais pourquoi les
futurs prédit ne se réalisent jamais
bon soit une question police pour nous
demander à quoi on sert
mais à cette question pourquoi les
futurs prédit ne se réalisent jamais il
ya une réponse assez simple c'est que ce
n'est tout simplement pas leur rôle
l'intérêt premier des futurs prédit
n'est pas de se réaliser
le futur n'est pas là pour confirmer que
vous aviez raison ou tort
à définir le futur
je dirais que ce n'est pas une certitude
et d'ailleurs nous sommes nombreux dans
la salle à l'avoir expérimenté
nous verrons ensemble qu'effectivement
le futur c'est un espace
de conscience mais que cette conscience
n'est pas suffisante et qu'à cette
conscience doit être associée une
compétence que nous appelons la
littératie des futures
mais pour comprendre un peu ce parcours
je vous demande effectivement de
devancer pour moi la route vers les
futures a été à travers les questions de
développement puisque on m'a fait
comprendre petit que j'appartiens dre
peut-être un continent qu'on dit
développés et donc je me posais la
question mais ce serait quoi justement
un pays développés
et par compte je pense que plein de
jeunes de ma génération ici présents en
france se poser cette question et
observer un certain temps de déconnexion
entre leurs aspirations d'un monde qui
pourrait être et la réalité d'un monde
qui probablement sera
est pour moi l'une des plus grandes
sources peut-être de cette déconnexion
provient notamment d'une navrante de
confusion entre le futur et les futures
le futur c'est tout ce qui va suivre
cette phrase tout ce qui après
maintenant
je devrais vous dire bienvenue dans le
futur mais ce serait vous mentir puisque
le futur n'existe pas au présent
mais il ya bien quelque chose qui existe
dans votre présent quand on parle du
futur
penser effectivement plutôt aux futurs
au pluriel qui sont un ensemble de
crainte d'espérance penser à un certain
nombre de décisions d'achat d'un scooter
d'élargissement de votre famille ou
peut-être l'achat compulsif de papier
toilette parce que le pire est à venir
vous voyez effectivement les figures
sont des espaces d'émotion ce qui veut
dire quelque chose d'assez important
qui est que les futurs possibles sont
bien plus large que les futurs qu'on dit
probable où les futurs qu'on vous dit
souhaitable
pourtant si vous réfléchissez au futur
qu'on vous annonce comme par exemple
pour mon oncle tanzanien qui lui avait
dit que c'était un futur décent ou un
futur probable
qu'est ce qui l'a amené effectivement à
se dire mais
sophie futur là c'est un futur pour moi
qui aujourd'hui a le droit de penser le
futur qui sont les ingénieurs du futur
les charpentiers du chef de futurs
construisait le futur dont on vous
bassine dans les publicités ou même dans
le métro quand vous vous promenez
vous rendez compte effectivement que le
futur est un espace de pouvoir
et ça me fait donc penser notamment aux
policiers aux politiciens aux
institutions de développement aux
organisations humanitaires
que vous avez peut-être élus payés pour
vous représenter pour vous rassurer pour
vous indiquer qu'il y a une vision long
terme et ces bases là effectivement que
vous sentez conforté dans l'idée d'un
futur qu'on connaît
mon métier à moi en tant que futuriste
ou spécialisés l'anticipation c'est de
convier convaincre ces personnes et de
vous convaincre aussi vous ce soir
de ne pas prédire ou en tout cas si vous
le fait de ne pas le faire pour les
mauvaises raisons
et pour le comprendre je vous demander
de vous prêter un exercice assez simple
si vous demandez à tous et toutes de
fermer les yeux
oui maintenant et pour mener par
l'exemple je vais le faire avec vous
en fermant les yeux vous diriger vers un
futur probable en 2060 du lieu dans
lequel vous vous trouvez à vous de
choisir l'échelle
ce futur et probable parce qu'il est
basé sur un certain nombre de
statistiques de courant de tendance
d'histoire de grand-mère qui vous font
penser mais oui ce futur aura lieu je
peux parier sur ce futur
avec qui est ce que vous communiquez à
quoi ressemble une journée typique dans
ce 2060 qu'est ce qui est de la valeur
pour vous en 2060
vous pouvez ouvrir les yeux
quand on réalise cet exercice
généralement en france sans attendre de
réponse reviennent régulièrement la
question de la robotisation de la
société le fait alors plus de temps
libre plus de contacts humains face à
effectivement des questions de santé
mentale vous pensez peut-être à des
situations tout simplement j'étudie
certaine harmonie avec la nature une
nature qui sait peut-être retourner
contre vous
vous pensez peut-être également à une
soif de décision collective face à la
tyrannie de la surveillance
et sont des tendances qu'on a vu axe
entier notamment avec la pandémie d'un
côté surveillance technologie de l'autre
survie de l'espèce retour à mère nature
mais vous remarquerez deux choses avec
ces tendances des futures la première
c'est que son effectuera ces macro mais
qu'on peut en fait répartir dans 4
catégories quatre archétypes c'est le
terme qu'on emploie au sein de l'école
hawaïenne des futurs
que chacun des futurs que je viens de
décrire peut rentrer dans la catégorie
catégorie croissance
stagnation chute ou transformation c'est
à dire que vous observez un phénomène en
et vous en disiez que peut-être ce
phénomène sera plus important en 2060 ça
peut être le cas par exemple avec la
recherche de contacts humains en 2060
plus de contacts humains au contraire
vous pensez que ce sera pareil en 2060
donc on pense à un phénomène de
stagnation ou alors
vous observez une baisse en 2060 et dont
on parle dans ce cas là de chute
s'il existe des facteurs de changements
internes ou externes on parlera alors de
transformation
croissance
stagnation chute transformation
finalement son et futurs qui ont une
particularité en eux mêmes mais la
deuxième chose qui doit vous alerter
c'est le fait effectivement de verviers
qui ce sont des futurs qui ont l'air
assez éloigné de nous
ils sont éloignés de nous pas seulement
parce que vous pouvez vous dire on déjà
on sait pas à quoi ressemblera 2023
alors 2060 ça semble un peu un peu
farfelu c'est pas la seule raison
c'est ce que les futurs que je viens de
vous décrire son et futurs qui sont
finalement assez impersonnel il ne
raconte pas d'histoire dit qu'après tout
le fait de savoir que vous viviez dans
une société robots en 2060 qu'est ce que
ça vous dit de votre relation avec votre
belle mère vos choix de paternité
ces futurs là ne vous décrivent pas
et pourtant on vous a dit que c'étaient
les vôtres
ce qu'on vient de faire ensemble c'est
déjà de prendre conscience du futur de
son existence dans notre quotidien deux
phénomènes qu'on appelle de
l'anticipation que vous avez dû
effectivement adressé tout simplement
même pour venir dans cette salle vous
avez dû prendre un certain nombre de
décisions en amont en ayant une certaine
idée de votre futur est ce que vous
attendiez elle dans cette salle à
entendre ces d'intervenants qui saura
mais en tout cas un certain nombre
d'éléments qui ont composé
votre désormais passé mais à l'époque
qui était votre présent
et vous rendez compte peut-être
que la conscience n'est pas suffisante
pour ce type de phénomène est d'ailleurs
parfois on a une très conscients des
choses dont nous ne voulons pas parler
je me rappelle d'un laboratoire d'un
atelier que je faisais avec des
financiers européens en 2019
ont leurs répliques explique la
méthodologie ce qu'on va faire ensemble
par les deux futurs probables futurs
souhaitables différents types de futur
pour ainsi revenir au présent
après avoir bien compris la méthodologie
ils nous expliquent qu'ils ne veulent
pas parler de futurs probables de futurs
souhaitables ayant attrait à la
décroissance
ils ne voulaient visiblement pas parler
de futures qui potentiellement pouvait
desservir leurs intérêts
est ce qu'on voit et qui est essentielle
effectivement par rapport à ces
questions des futurs c'est qu'en vérité
les futurs sont des marqueurs d'intérêt
sont des espaces de pouvoir
penser peut-être en pleine élection on
en période d'élection électorales en
france il ya un stand de sujets sur le
futur de la france quels sont les sujets
qu'on traite et les chutes sujet qu'on
ne traite pas
et vous rendrez compte que les futures
ne sont jamais innocents les futures ne
sont jamais neutres
et pourtant comme dans le cas des
banquiers même si vous ne traitez pas
certaines thématiques
ça n'empêchera pas qu'elles apparaissent
ce qui pose notamment la question des
choix qu'on fait de l'humilité que ça
demande aussi à se dire que le
changement se produit aussi sans vous
j'aimerais donc vous parler d'un projet
qui nous tient à coeur que je mène
depuis 18 mois depuis le début de
l'année 2020 avec des réfugiés syriens
je forme un groupe de futuriste amateurs
qui s'intéressent à porter les
discussions au sein de familles
syriennes présentes au liban sur le
futur
peut-être que vous poserez la question
de et des calmes avec des réfugiés
syriens est-ce que leur présence n'est
pas plus pressant que des questions du
futur 2060 2035 vous choisirez la
temporalité
mais en fait on avec un groupe qui s'est
rendu compte que quel que soit l'urgence
du présent
ce sont des images du futur
qui dicte les comportements des réfugiés
syriens ces sont des images de paix de
guerre
ou de tout autre phénomène qui vont les
amener à penser comment est-ce que j'ai
protégé ma famille aujourd'hui en
réaction directe à des images du futur
pourtant quand on pense aux questions de
futurs de la migration les premiers
éléments qu'on a souvent sur le devant
de la table c'est par exemple comment ça
peut être une aubaine face à le
vieillissement de la population
européenne pour pouvoir une main
d'oeuvre jeune dynamique prête à
travailler on va parler les difficultés
du contrôle des frontières par les
politiques frontex 2min européenne
et vous remarqué d éternel absent de ces
futures où sont les réfugiés syriens
dans les futurs de la migration dont je
viens de parler
nulle part
parce qu'ils sont pensés comme des
personnes passive juridiquement et donc
nécessairement leur futur est narrée
pour eux ils ne sont pas dans ses futurs
là pourtant si on avait pris le temps de
les écouter ils auraient pu entendre
comme moi cette mère de famille de deux
enfants qui nous explique qu'elle est
prête à retourner en syrie
si ça peut lui permettre d'envoyer ses
deux enfants à l'école ce qui
actuellement le liban
fait face effectivement une grande crise
de son système éducatif
qui affecte les libanais évidemment
d'autres populations encore plus
marginalisées
prétendre sur le territoire libanais
vous rendez compte de la détermination
de cette femme qui effectivement est en
train de vous dire que quoi qu'il arrive
elle pourrait se rendre en séries
mais c'est donc val parle quand elle dit
qu'elle veut retourner en syrie elle ne
parle pas d'un retour absolue en syrie
ce n'est pas un désir de syrie à
proprement parler il s'agit d'un désir
d'un retour
un territoire d'options un territoire
d'opportunités pour sa famille
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'effectivement si l'état libanais où
les états européens souhaitent
l'accompagner dans son projet l'objectif
ne sera pas nécessairement de la faire
retourner en syrie juste pour pouvoir se
débarrasser d'elle ce sera effectivement
de voir comment en résolvant un problème
qui les concernent directement à eux en
tant qu' état libanais ils pourront
aussi répondre à d'autres problématiques
qui touchent d'autres populations
marginalisées en leur sein et c'est
d'autant plus important que condamnent
en art pas les futurs des réfugiés
syriens il n'empêche que dix ans après
il reste comme représenteront plus du
tiers de la population libanaise
c'est un appel à l'humilité à l'humilité
pourquoi parce que ce qu'on entend par
là c'est que le changement a toujours
lieu il est toujours en cours
mais le choc changement ne provient pas
que de vous
et en écoutant effectivement cette jeune
femme je me suis rendu compte avant
d'éléments qui peuvent nous paraître
problématique par rapport au futur
problématique parce qu'on se dit oui on
est conscient de certaines
problématiques
conscient d'intérêt en présence qui ne
sont pas forcément les nôtres mais
comment les intégrer
et c'est peut-être ça qui nous fait peur
avoir peur du futur
penser que le futur effectivement est
problématique
problématique mais en vérité ce qu'on
adresse c'est un passé et un présent qui
sont problématiques parce que le futur
n'est pas un problème mais surtout ce
n'est pas un problème à résoudre c'était
pas un problème à paramétrer ou à régler
le futur
c'est l'occasion pour nous d'être
confronté au miroir de nos autres
cessions d'être confrontés à nos propres
contradictions
ce que j'observe à travers ce phénomène
c'est peut-être cinq choses par rapport
au futur
les futurs son
humilité dialogue imagination
négociations et actions
humilité parce que finalement le futur
n'existe pas et on commençait pas
grand-chose
dialogue parce que c'est toujours mieux
d'imaginer à plusieurs
imagination parce que comme le futur
n'existe pas il faut le créer
négociations parce que nécessairement on
se rend compte qu'on est confronté à des
intérêts contradictoires et que tous
nous constituerons une partie de ce
changement là
mais nous faut prendre le temps
effectivement peut-être près de
l'entendre
et actions
parce que une fois qu'on est plus alerte
plus conscients plus compétents dans
notre approche des futurs qu'on comprend
pourquoi et comment nous anticipons
qu'on comprend vraiment le rôle que joue
notre imagination
à pouvoir créer des conditions de
changement chacun d'entre nous dans la
salle
nécessairement on se retrouve mieux
positionné pour agir
est ce que je vais vous demander
effectivement à tous en quittant cette
salle
c'est parler à certains de vos proches
et de leur demander
qu'est ce que vous pensez effectivement
du futur en 2060 vous pouvez choisir un
futur programme souhaitable ça n'a pas
d'importance n'importe quel futur
possible
demandez-leur effectivement ce qu'ils en
pensent
mais vous remarquerez peut-être quelque
chose la première chose c'est que vous
remarquerez peut-être des archétypes
limitant le fait qu'effectivement il
parle peut-être de fusion extérieur à
eux mêmes
mais vous remarquerez aussi autre chose
c'est que vous venez de créer un
dialogue
et ça c'est une aventure bien trop belle
pour en laisser le monopole à quiconque
parce que n'oubliez pas
j'ai commencé en vous disant que le
changement était en soit toujours en
cours en vous disant aussi que le
changement ne dépend pas que de vous
mais il n'avait pas encore ajouté
que le changement vous en fait
nécessairement partie
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]